would you rather give up appetizers or
desserts for life big facts dessert boy
come over here with your Swedish I am
big on cakes pies ice creams appetizers
you know it's like an opening act most
of the time you're like wasn't that good
didn't need I am an opening act so it
does hurt a little bit when I say that
but but as sometimes
please keep hiring me Hollywood as an
opening it
no but definitely desserts oh fired you
know what you already had the closer a
steak and someone brings out a
you talk with multi chocolate molten can
I cut it open it's a magic trick son
I almost got magic tricks and an
appetizer
Bang Bang Shrimp get the [__] out of my
face I got a moon cake dog dessert